الاجازات انواع يعني سنويه مرضيه عرضيه
امومه عبوه يعني كلها انواع انجازات ما
تعرف عليها فاهمينها يعني لكن في دراسه
امريكيه جديده طلعت لنا بنوع اجازه جديده
والمطالبين بنوع الاجابه الاجازه هذه هم
جنريشن زي او الجيل والمقصود بهذه المصطلح
هم المواليد ما بين 97 لغايه 2012
سنوات ل 25 سنه نوع الاجازه اللي يعني
اللي بكلمكم عنها هنا الطالب فيها او
بيتطلبوا فيها بحسب الدراسه الامريكيه
اكثر من 82% من الموظفين اللي من جناريشن
همم زيد هي اجازه للصحه العقليه يعني
بطالبه انه الواحد فيهم لما النفسيه تتعب
او يحس انه متضايق يكون هذا عذر يخلي ياخذ
اوف من الشغل يكلم مدير ويقول له انا
نفسيتي تعبانه يعني الدراسه بتقول كمان
انه يعني مع الانفتاح اللي صاير في الحديث
عن الصحه النفسيه واختفاء وصفه العار جيل
الجديد هذا اجرا في الكلام عن الصحه
النفسيه والعقليه واهميتها لكن حقيقه
الدراسه هذه اثارت عندي الكثير من السجون
ابرزها انه احنا يعني
بنتكلم عن زي مثل ما قلنا يعني اللي منهم
بيشتغلوا هم ناس يعني اعمارهم نقول ما بين
21 و25 سنه يعني هدول ايش شافوا عشان من
الان يطلبوا باجازه الصحه نفسيه وايش خلي
مثلا اللي بعد خمسه ولا عشره سنين شغل
عموما خلينا نناقش يعني عشان ما اكون
ظالماهم يمكن عندهم اسباب خلونا نناقش
الموضوع ضيفنا المفضل في ما يخص الصحه
النفسيه من عمان دكتور ليث العبادي الطبيب
النفسي اهلا فيك معنا همم دكتور همم ليث
يعني صراحه انه هل طبيعي انه 82% من هذا
الامنجيل همم زاد اللي هم احنا بنقول انه
بي 21 ل 25 سنه يبقوا اجازات لصحتهم
النفسيه
دائما بس اكون معكم بشكل عام واحد من كل
اربعه سيحتاج ان يرى طبيب نفسي خلال حياته
يعني 25% فلا شك
اذا بدنا نحكي عن حاجه لاجازه بسبب مشكله
نفسيه قد لا تصل الى هذا الرقم ولكن دائما
الاجازه تحسن النفسيه دائما للراحه تعطيك
استرخاء انبساط فهو في خلط صار ما بين
الجزء الرفاه وما بين الحاج الاساسيه
العلاجيه كاجاز مرضيه او اجازه خاصه نفسيه
ممكن يسموها اعجاز للرفاهيه اجازه استمتاع
زي اجازه عاديه ممكن يطالبه بتوسيع
الاجازات الثانويه
او ممكن يطالبه بتمديد الاجازات المرضيه
بشكل عام ولكن احنا المطالبات جايه من
الانفتاح وتقليل وصله العراق طب انت لما
تفصل الاجازه النفسيه عن الاجازات الاخرى
انت كانك عملت نوع من وصله العاب احنا
بنحاول قدر الانسان
موظف ويقول انه معلش انا اليوم متضايق
نفسيتي تعبانه يعني بليز راح اخذ اوف
صراحه يعني بالنسبه لبقيت الموظفين
الموضوع المنظر ما هيكون واو ما يكون رهيب
ابدا
السلوك فعلا ياثر على الناس على نفسيته
سلبا لاحقا
انه ليش تحديدا هذا الجيل يعني انت بتقول
اوكي مرتاحين اكثر والدراسه بتقول انهم
مرتاحين اكثر في التعبير عن همم انه موضوع
الامراض النفسيه او التعب النفسي وما الى
ذلك بس صراحه كمان خليني اقول لك اياها من
الناحيه الثانيه ترى ثلاثه ارباع اللي
موجودين شايفين انهم مدلعين انه هذه لا
هذا دلع
يعني
احنا بنطلع على شيء اسمه المنع عن النفسيه
واللي ممكن تكون اقل عند فئات معينه ما
بقدر اجزم منه
ما له علاقه
بالعمر بعدين دكتور ليث الصراحه يعني معلش
يعني سوري
يعني اذا هم بدهم اجازه الصحه نفسيه انا
روحت قاعد يعني دحين مبكر يعني ولا ايش
اسوي
انا نفسيتي تعبانه كمان كل يوم بصحه
تعبانه
دائما الجيل الاكبر وانا مش من هذا الجيل
فما بدافع عنهم بس دايما في ظلم من
الاجيال على اللي اصغر منهم دايما انه هذا
الجيل وهذا الجيل من الاف السنين الاف
السنين في احفورات تتكلم انه والله هذا
الجيل مش زي الجيلنا وهذا الجيل الجديد
خربان نائم يعني في نوع من الظلم هو مستمر
هو جزء من من الطباع البشريه المنصوره
لا يوجد ضعف او قله منع نفسيه بس قلت مانع
يعني عدم القدره على الاستجابه على الضغوط
فقد يكون شيء يزيد من تعبيرهم وبعض
المطالبات باجازات نفسيه
طيب
بشكل عام انا انا بكون صاحب الازازات بشكل
عام
يا سيدي نشتغل يومين في الاسبوع مو مشكله
يا سيدي ناخد رواتب من غير شغل مش مشكله
بس نحن بنتكلم
طيب
كل ما الها الشركات بتشعر تحت الضغط انها
لازم تنفذ الموظفين هذه الاشياء ولا
بيشتكوا مشاكل وكده برايك كيف التعامل مع
هذه المطالبات
المرضيه بشكل عام ممكن
ينعمل النظام
سلوك الانسانيه
[موسيقى]
في الحياه يعني
التعب هو جزء من الحياه هذا زي ما في تعب
جسدي في تعب نفسي تعب النفسي
المرض الذي يؤدي الى اذا وصلت لمرحله انت
بحاجه ان تاخذ اجازه بسبب التعب النفسي
مره تمام بس اذا تكرر هذا الموضوع واصبح
العمل يتا
ثر بسبب وضعك لنفسي هنا انت تحتاج ان ترى
مختص وان تبدا في العلاج وقت ممكن الطبيب
يعطيك تقريره وعلى فكره تقبل للمؤسسات لن
تقارير من الاطباء النفسيه ملاحظه الشخصيه
صار افضل يعني ممكن تشرح انه هذا الشخص
مره في مرحله التعب بدون ما يكون هو في
وصمه العار انه انا ما بقدر احكي
فعلا
اوف ونقول تعبانين نفسيا
طبيه ممتاز شكرا لك من عمان دكتور طبيب
نفسي شكرا